qué tal Muy buenas tardes Pues sí
efectivamente en los exteriores de esta
corte Federal aquí en la ciudad de Miami
en Florida hay un clima de Gran tensión
numerosos simpatizantes del ex
mandatario como también algunos
detractores se han dado cita con
banderas de Estados Unidos también con
carteles de apoyo y también numerosos
agentes de policía de la ciudad como
también agentes federales han están
custodiando en estos momentos todos los
accesos a este edificio porque la
prioridad es evitar los disturbios hace
pocas horas incluso efectivos de la
policía estaban viendo un paquete
sospechoso incluso han tenido que
desalojar toda esta zona donde estamos
los periodistas también muchísimos
medios de comunicación se han dado cita
en este lugar una cita que algunos ya la
califican de histórica
cómo está previsto que sea el operativo
no para lo que será la comparecencia de
Donald Trump
si se espera que poco después de las dos
de la tarde hora de Miami el
exmandatario acceda a este edificio a
través de un parking subterráneo es por
lo tanto es muy poco probable que
tengamos esa imagen del expresidente
entrando a este edificio a pie una vez
dentro de ese parking subterráneo va a
entrar a la oficina para poderle tomar
las huellas dactilares también las
fotografías no se sabe si va a ser
esposado y después de eso va a entrar en
la en la sala para que empiece esa
comparecencia ahí va a estar el juez
también la fiscalía los abogados Y por
supuesto también el expresidente Donald
Trump para que empiece esta
comparecencia donde se le van a leer de
manera formal esos 37 cargos a los que
se enfrenta por este proceso de mal
manejo de documentación clasificada
hablemos Anthony ahora un poco más
concretamente de la acusación no estos
documentos de lo que estamos hablando
Incluso en algunos de los secretos más
sensibles para Estados Unidos Cuáles son
los principales que han trascendido
sí Donald Trump se enfrenta a 37 cargos
por mal manejo de documentación
son documentos que fueron hallados en su
residencia de Mara lago 31 de esos
cargos tiene que ver con la ley de
espionaje de Estados Unidos que es toda
retención no autorizada de información
de defensa nacional es decir cualquier
tipo de documento fotografía email que
pueda utilizarse en perjuicio de Estados
Unidos o En beneficio de cualquier país
extranjero hay que recordar que esos 31
documentos estaban marcados como
secretos o de alto secretos y tener esos
documentos en su poder ya es suficiente
para mostrar para presentar esos cargos
Esta es la situación en estos momentos
aquí en la sede Federal de la corte
Federal de Miami aquí en Florida
esperando la del expresidente Donald
Trump que podría ser su llegada en
alrededor de las dos de la tarde según
han informado Fuentes judiciales